you've broken everything  you're  suffering is almost  at an end  dear billy  i don't know if you can even hear this  [Music]  ever since you left everything's been  a total disaster  for a while we tried to be happy  normal  i know that's impossible  i relocated you guys far from hawkins  [Music]  because i thought you'd be safe  [Music]  a war is coming  i'm afraid your friends at hawkins are  very much  in the eye of the storm  i don't have my powers  i don't know how to say this other than  just to say it  [Music]  without you  [Music]  we can't win this war  [Music]  see on the other side  on the other side  [Music]  i was convinced i was put here for some  other  [Music]  reason i can still help  even if it's the last thing i do  [Music]  people say hawkins is cursed  they're not  way off  it's time  you  have laws  [Music]  you